Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 Soy Paula Jiménez Correa en
esta ocasión por mi colega herminia
Fernández
en este episodio lo llevaremos a África
específicamente al norte de Costa de
Marfil en donde ronda La amenaza del
yihadismo situada en la frontera con
burkina faso la región es utilizada por
los grupos armados como zona de
repliegue en tan solo dos años se han
cometido cinco atentados no
reivindicados el más grave ocurrió en
junio de 2020 contra un puesto del
ejército en la ciudad de cafolo el cual
dejó 14 muertos siguieron otros ataques
y las autoridades trabajan para mejorar
la situación de seguridad nuestros
corresponsales Samuel Bernard y hannahni
pudieron unirse al ejército en patrullas
antiterroristas y conocer a los
residentes locales en esta región
fronteriza el pueblo fulani asegura ser
objeto de especial vigilancia y Denuncia
lo que considera medidas
discriminatorias las fuerzas de
seguridad por su parte niegan a haber
tenido como objetivo algún grupo
específico en su lucha contra el
terrorismo Esta es la historia
[Música]
en este puesto de control en Kong a 600
kilómetros de avian y las fuerzas de
seguridad se preparan para una salida
nocturna
esta noche se reportó la presencia de
individuos sospechosos en los
alrededores muy cerca de la frontera con
burkina faso toda persona sospechosa
detenida deberá ser requisada siguiendo
los procedimientos operacionales que
ustedes ya conocen
habrá dos patrullas
y la otra la zona de Turbo
estos militares están presentes en el
extremo noreste del territorio desde que
ocurrió el primer ataque yihadista en la
región en junio de 2020 a bordo de
vehículos blindados y en convoy
los escuadrones se dirigen hacia la
frontera
[Música]
trabajamos en un área complicada
puede haber enemigos que desaceleren
nuestro plan de acción
y pongan trampas a lo largo de nuestra
ruta
El Limón
la unidad principal vio movimientos
sospechosos en la vía
se bajaron y están haciendo un registro
vamos a ver de qué se trata Por eso nos
dirigimos hacia esa zona
por precaución los militares avanzan
despacio y en fila India esta noche no
hay artefactos explosivos a la vista
Pero a 200 metros de nuestro vehículo
descubrieron un cráter en el suelo los
yihadistas no alcanzaron a poner una
mina entierran la carga y conservan la
fuente de energía
después monitorean las veces que pasamos
y así puede entendernos una emboscada
puentes como este son el objetivo
principal de los grupos armados hace dos
semanas muy cerca de aquí esta unidad
fue atacada antes de hacer retroceder a
los atacantes son altercados recurrentes
que el ejército no suele hacer públicos
Esta es la zona de mayor riesgo
cuando hay alguna alerta en cafolo desde
esta zona hasta el segundo punto
sabemos que es muy posible caer en una
emboscada Entonces nos movemos con mucha
precaución por todo este perímetro es la
primera vez en dos años que el ejército
permite que los medios internacionales
asistan a una de sus operaciones
antiterroristas en el norte de manera
oficial las autoridades afirman haber
recuperado el control de la zona pero el
discurso repetido por el teniente kambal
no es muy convincente el riesgo siempre
es muy alto
pero lo manejamos como dije antes
estamos entrenados para eso y bueno
Tratamos de llevar a cabo nuestra misión
como es debido y de tranquilizar a la
población
los refuerzos siguen llegando a la zona
donde ya hay cuatro mil hombres a pesar
de la Calma la región Aún es vulnerable
porque se encuentra en una franja del
sagel amenazada por el terrorismo
cafolo fue el escenario del primer
ataque yihadista Todo cambió en la noche
del 10 al 11 de junio de 2020 cuando los
tiros despertaron a los habitantes del
pueblo paterna se acuerda de esa noche
fue aquí
había impactos de bala sangre
pero yo no estaba
trabajo en el campo cada mañana pasó por
aquí pero la verdad no fui capaz de ver
los cuerpos de las personas eran los
cuerpos de 14 militares y marfileños su
puesto de control blanco del ataque dejó
un gran vestigio en la tierra la
incursión se consideró como una
represalia por una operación militar
conjunta para desalojar a unos
yihadistas instalados en la zona un
golpe duro para Costa de Marfil cuatro
años después de letal atentado de Gran
Bazán cuando los cazadores se iban al
monte decían que veían gente extraña
entonces sabíamos que había allíhadistas
por ahí pero no pensábamos que fueran a
atacar cafolo
nueve meses después dos soldados y un
gendarme marfileño murieron aquí junto
con tres terroristas
le pedimos a Dios que nos regresen
dos veces es demasiado
paterno y nos trajo a este hotel que
solía estar lleno de turistas
extranjeros
ahora no hay ningún visitante
antes del primer ataque paterna dirigía
a un grupo de teatro local que se
presentaba en este lugar
todo está cerrado
Pero antes habría en la puerta y
nosotros estábamos aquí
el público se sentaba y el espectáculo
era acá era Bueno pero hoy ya no es así
los empleados se fueron los guías ya no
están ni siquiera está el auto todo el
mundo se fue las personas ya no trabajan
antes trabajaban aquí
cada fin de mes todos recibían algo
aunque no fuera mucho
pero ahora no hay nada
solo quedan dos empleados que cuidan los
jardines y alimentan a unos chimpancés
es muy triste Por eso digo que los
yihadistas ganaron
lograron cambiar la vida de cafolo
ya no tenemos recursos no hay nada ahora
es así a pesar de un gran despliegue del
ejército a lo largo de la frontera la
economía local está muy afectada
agricultores y Pescadores sufren las
consecuencias de la inseguridad los
grupos que amenazan la región no se
limitan a los ataques armados también
generan miedo intimidando a las
poblaciones como en este pueblo a pocos
kilómetros de la frontera con burkina
faso hace un año llegaron unos
individuos armados reunieron a la
población alrededor de la mezquita y
acusaron a algunas personas de ser
informantes de las fuerzas de seguridad
nacionales
estábamos aquí rezamos aquí a las 7 o
7:30 de la noche
en ese momento llegaron a la mezquita
este campesino aceptó hablar con
nosotros a condición de permanecer
anónimo vinieron en moto eran dos o tres
en cada una
había muchas cuando llegaron agruparon a
toda la gente aquí
dijeron que eran Eso que la gente llama
yihadistas sobre los que se hablaba por
televisión y radio dijeron que a partir
de ese día iban a estar aquí
y que no debíamos hablar con las fuerzas
de seguridad
no los conocemos pero ellos dijeron que
nos conocían a todos cuando vinieron
mencionaron los nombres de algunas
personas del pueblo dijeron que conocían
a todo el mundo desde entonces ha
cambiado la vida en el pueblo los
locales evitan hacer viajes largos
ninguna moto circula después de las 6 de
la tarde tenemos miedo y los que tienen
miedo ya no van al campo Muy pocas
personas lo hacen el mío está 7
kilómetros de aquí
hace meses que no voy
para ganar dinero simplemente no las
arreglamos nos las arreglamos
los habitantes han tratado de pasar la
página del terror
pero se ha instalado la desconfianza en
la región
se sospecha de una comunidad en
particular
los pastores seminómadas de la etnia
fulani al día siguiente del primer
ataque en cafolo las fuerzas de
seguridad detuvieron a varios
responsables entre ellos un fulani de
burkina faso actualmente las autoridades
locales vigilan muy de cerca los
miembros de esta etnia presentes en la
región desde hace varios años los
fulanian han sido señalados en la lucha
contra el terrorismo en Mali y burkina
faso según Fuentes militares se estima
que hay entre 35.000 y 40.000 en la
región marfileña de vonkani deja que los
animales crucen
la comunidad suele vivir en campamentos
situados en medio del monte para
mantenerse cerca del ganado desde que
comenzaron los ataques su vida se ha
precarizado
los fulanis son Víctimas de persecución
dicen que somos yihadistas
pero no tenemos nada que ver con ese
asunto
estos dos pastores nacieron y crecieron
en Costa de Marfil Esta es la única
región que conocen
la Situación ha cambiado mucho
antes podíamos hacer ceremonias de boda
reunirnos
los fulani venían de todas partes para
participar en esos eventos ahora ya no
se puede
si se organiza una boda y viene un
desconocido lo detienen por el camino
ya no se puede visitar a otras personas
No se puede viajar 10 kilómetros en moto
no puedo mover mi ganado de un Arroyo a
otro sin correr el riesgo de que me
detengangan
detuvieron a muchos jóvenes y se los
llevaron hace meses por ejemplo
uno de nosotros se fue a cortar hierba
para construir un techo
cuando las autoridades lo vieron lo
detuvieron
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es el jefe de un pequeño pueblo llamado
nazian es una figura respetada en el
departamento y se ha dedicado a ayudar a
la comunidad fulani a la que conoce muy
bien los militares los molestaron en el
camino nos hicieron preguntas pero no
hubo problemas
Dios nos libre
no tengan miedo
eviten salir de noche si no se meten en
asuntos raros vamos a poder ayudarles
acuanenemos nada más haciendo afuera
voy a llamar el comandante de la brigada
para saludarlo en los últimos meses va
Soria ha ayudado a liberar una decena de
miembros de la comunidad fulani ha ido
varias veces en personas hasta la
estación de policía de con para
testimoniar a favor de los jóvenes
detenidos y firmar cartas de compromiso
para obtener su Liberación según él lo
más importante es no ceder a la
tentación del conflicto intercomunitario
apenas los militares ver a un fulano y
lo detienen
si lo ven en el camino se lo llevan
a veces van a estar los campamentos
pero son seres humanos
cuando llegaron los instalamos aquí
cuando estaban instalados empezamos a
trabajar juntos ahora convivimos sin
problema la situación humanitaria Es
grave como humanos debería dolernos ver
que nuestro semejantes los maltratan
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vasori Espera que la mejora del contexto
de seguridad permita apaciguar las
relaciones entre las comunidades por su
parte las fuerzas de seguridad aseguran
no discriminar ninguna etnia en su lucha
contra el terrorismo Costa de Marfil
anunció un reclutamiento de 10.000
soldados a lo largo de los próximos tres
años para aumentar las filas de su
ejército
finaliza este capítulo de reporteros Los
invito a visitar nuestra página web
France 24.com para ver este y otros
reportajes Gracias por acompañarnos
sigan con toda nuestra programación
[Música]